TV
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
Fiona Bruce have their 15 Minutes of
Shame at the hands of the Pitchfork
self-righteous mob but this is a Tipping
Point for cancel culture or debate
and the grown-ups are back in child
seemingly with a budget that didn't take
the pound Block mortgage rates or
crashed the markets that's how low the
bar is is it too late for the Tories to
recover their reputation in time for the
election
Pastor prosecutor who bound to take down
Alec Baldwin steps aside in a rare
booster disgraced star but will you
still end up behind bars
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
Ashley Gooding from a gridlocked London
it's taken me one hour and 45 minutes to
travel four miles
from West London to another part of West
London because of all the strikes 600
000 workers apparently were out today uh
when does this end when does the misery
for all those who aren't striking who
don't want Barrel loads more cash in the
middle of a cost of living crisis when
does this stop when can normal people
get back to work and go to work no it
won't take them three days to get home I
just asked the question because it's
incredibly annoying if the strikers
think that we're all ending our day
after days like this thinking you know
what you must do go out and support the
strikers they're living in Cloud Cuckoo
Land
anyway that's off my chest it's been a
torrid week for those who insisted
cancel culture either doesn't matter or
doesn't exist first Gary denica was
mobbed and then suspended for his
opinions about the government's migrant
policy next Fiona Bruce was denounced as
an apologist for domestic violence over
this
for a change I'm not
I'm not blaming Boris Johnson or Stanley
Johnson actually can he was a wife
beater Stanley Johnson on record
um okay let me just let me just
interview I'm not I'm not disputing what
we're saying but just so everyone knows
what this is referring to so Sally
Johnson's uh wife spoke to a journalist
on bar and she said that Stanley Johnson
had broken her nose and she'd end up in
hospital as a result Stanley Johnson has
not commented publicly on that friends
of his have said it did happen it was a
one-off yes but it did happen
well that was it Fiona Bruce was
directed to read a prepared statement
for legal reasons this kind of thing
happens all the time by the way in live
television I'll occasionally have
something I have to read which is just
part of what you do as a live news
presenter if you think someone's going
to make an inflammatory statement you
have something that you can counter it
it's called you know being fat being
reasonable about these things if Jenna
Brooks didn't pass judgment she didn't
give a personal opinion she read a BBC
statement of context on legal advice
that she was directed to do but the
righteous mob don't care about the
nuances of these things members of
parliament said that she was disgraceful
petitions circular demanding she'd be
fired outraged keyboard Warriors
described a sickening this is Fiona
Bruce we're talking about
and refuge the domestic violence charity
the Fiona Bruce are represented with
distinction for 25 years dropped her
like a rock
with both Fiona Bruce and Gary Unica the
reaction was hysterical but entirely
predictable
ridiculous overreactions to words and
opinions have become the norm in our
society step out of line one word out of
line You'll Be vilified shamed and
censored until there are consequences
till you get canceled ruined Atlantic
approved it doesn't matter if your left
wing right wing white black old Young
Rich or poor and as Jeremy Clarkson
proved in aftermath of his ham visited
joke about Meghan Markle doesn't make
any difference if you issue a groveling
series of apologies the mob doesn't care
and nor do the people who get the
apologies Megan and Harry loved it but
in that case apologize for everything
else you've ever said and written was
their response my question is simply
this do we actually want to live in this
kind of world
a world in which everybody has to walk
around with their buttocks clenched in
Terror of being castigated for something
they've said or written of losing their
their job their livelihood their
reputation a world where Fiona Bruce and
trust me on this one of the nicest and
most respected people in the news
business on British television
is absurdly condemned as some kind of
wicked pariah
we used to talk about 15 minutes of fame
that was the Andy Warhol thing no
everyone gets their 15 Minutes of Shame
and the lucky ones survive it many don't
and I make no apology for loudly and
repeatedly calling out this madness for
what it is
well joining me now has talked to be
contributor Esther cracker writer and
commentator Larissa Kennedy and domestic
abuse Survivor Rachel Williams let me
start with you Rachel Williams
I was led to believe by the howling mob
that anyone who'd suffered domestic
abuse who watched question time was
traumatized by what happened that they
watched what Fiona Bruce said and felt
instant trauma over what they themselves
had gone through did you feel that
I did not Pierce and I can honestly
agree with you that Fiona Bruce is a
great advocate for the cause I was
fortunate to meet Fiona Bruce at
Buckingham Palace last year and she gave
me a big hug and I could tell she was
really supportive of the cause and I
think she's just been absolutely
crucified on social media and in the
press for repeating a comment that
somebody else had made right and the
truth is from a legal perspective if
you're a journalist you have the
allegations that were made by Stanley
Johnson's ex-wife which appeared in this
book and he's never responded publicly
he's just given his version through
friends and that's what she was
summarizing as a right of reply because
what else could she possibly do and for
that she had to give up a 25 year role
as an ambassador for Refuge I think I
think Shane's Refuge frankly let me go
now to Larissa Kennedy Larissa do you
you really feel the Fiona Bruce
had to be treated this way
I think when we're talking about how
people are being treated Fiona Bruce
herself chose to step down from this
role given the response from both
beneficiaries of refuge and from other
you know people who have experienced
domestic violence but also other forms
of gendered violence who felt hurt by
the comment and that's not to say that
this is some sort of canceling or
whatever we want to call it it's rather
to say that you know I I take pride in
this role but I also mean that with when
coming with pride comes responsibility
what did she do wrong
okay let's unpack it even if you believe
that her everything that she said was
absolutely correct in the fact that she
had to allow a Rite of reply I think no
one would have had an issue up until the
point in the sentence at which she said
it was a one-off because the framing
itself
implies some sort of diminishing of
these she did
hang on on that point on that point
Loris hang on look Fiona Bruce didn't
say it was a one-off
she said this is what this is she said
she said that is what friends of Stanley
Johnson have said by way a response
which by the way is entirely well hang
on hang on we don't want to hear this
let me finish That's What Friends of
Stanley Johnson have told people that's
been the only response he's given she
was actually she was accurately giving
the other side of this she wasn't saying
that is true or that is my opinion she
was simply giving a legal right to reply
because that's what we do in this
business
which I was about to acknowledge and say
that
the actress the act and who gave it to
her to say because in fact not
acknowledging that there would be
backlash from stating it in that way is
ridiculous I don't know how anyone can
work in this business and not understand
that for someone to say one-off sounds
as though you're calling anyone a form
of violence when it comes to gender
violence and domestic abuse
let me unpack what you've just said
here's the point I don't know the answer
nor does Fiona Bruce we don't know how
many times Stanley Johnson may or may
not have hit his wife right all we know
is what she has said and he's not
responded publicly other than to tell
people off the Record through friends it
was a one-off that might be true we
don't know it's it's a journalist's job
to try and find out but short of
actually having hard evidence to
corroborate that she did what I think
any news journalist would do in that
situation and simply gave the other side
from his point of view and said that
he's told people it was a one-off that
is the situation that we know about now
that may be lies and he might have been
a repeat offender and certainly his his
wife said that but we don't know that
for for a fact why should we act as
judge and jury against Stanley Johnson
in that circumstance I'm curious
we shouldn't but the phrase one-off
implies some sort of judgment there
because as you say but it wasn't Fiona
Bruce that said someone had appears if I
had hit you with my car and I hadn't
made a public statement statement about
it and someone else had said oh but it's
only a one-off would you feel
comfortable that the implication is that
they are I'm not someone who goes around
hitting people in my car and that's a
far less serious form of abuse that
we're talking and far less emotive in
many cases it's about being cautious
with language and this isn't about
canceling it's about saying I'm going to
take a step back from this have a little
think about how I approach this in
future that isn't what happened that
isn't what happened what happened is
that refugees hang on let me finish
Refuge who she'd worked for for 25 years
and we've just heard from Rachel that
Fiona meant this and this was a cause
important to her that she dedicated 25
years of her life to promoting a charity
that combating domestic violence nobody
would do would want to do less to
trivialize this issue than Fiona Bruce
she's proved that over 25 years and she
read out a short statement on legal
advice simply giving the other side from
what Stanley Johnson had told people was
his position about what his wife had
said and for that she's had to leave
Refuge as an ambassador and they dumped
her to the walls in a statement which I
thought was was shatteringly cowardly
and pathetic let me go to Esther
here's my problem with this it's the
Glee with which everyone seemed to want
to take down Fiona Bruce I mean they
make it impossible for people to exist
in public life anyone who knows what a
proper journalist's job is knows that
they have to give the other side of the
story but remain impartial as best you
know it exactly and she didn't pass any
judgment she didn't say this is right or
wrong this person this the person that
she was speaking to called him a wife
beater live on there nobody said
anything in defense of of Sonny Johnson
or not in defense of him but somehow she
reading a legal statement which actually
protects the BBC from Liberal lawsuits
yes somehow that makes her the enemy and
I think these people don't understand
they make it very difficult for anyone
to exist in public life because they
hold people to ridiculous standards I
think if you're going to take down Fiona
Bruce over something like this nobody is
safe from this absolutely nobody is safe
and then that's when people feel more
incentivized to be incendiary because
they said if I can't get away from it I
mean might as well just play that game
and then you raise tensions because
people feel the need to just play fire
with fire and there is a kind of Glee
isn't there we saw it with Gary deniker
as well from people on the right and if
it had been if lineker had been
supporting you know being a right-wing
commentator presenting sport who just
saves Matt Leticia right get in the
other side I think it would have been
all the people defending in the kid
would have been paying for his blood so
it works both ways this this mob
mentality but linnica the Glee with
which conservative MPS and conservative
pundits and so on would were trying to
destroy his career they'd have a hard
time doing that it was it was sort of
you know painful to watch in a in a
Democratic Society I felt painful to
watch someone being so
self-righteously condemned for his
opinion when all he was trying to do
albeit I think in a misguided way the
way he phrased this all he was trying to
do was stand up for refugees that was
his crime all that Fiona Bruce was
trying to do was was get some balance in
the middle of of a debate because that's
her job as the moderator of question
time just to make sure there's always a
right of reply if someone's not there to
a serious allegation that's made we're
in a situation now where the children
are in charge they're no adults in the
room so whenever someone feels offended
or they feel slighted or they don't
agree with someone they happen to have
the loudest voice and we have to go in
the direction that they they want to go
in and the inmates are running the
Asylum this I don't agree with with what
Gary lineker said but I in this in the
spirit of free speech which
conservatives ironically championed yeah
I don't believe he should have lost his
job or even should have been taken off
it and with Fiona Bruce this is even
more ridiculous because there was no
offense given quite frankly these people
are making it impossible for rational
spaces where people can speak freely to
exist and that's going to have a
detrimental effect right and I think um
Rachel just coming back to you I do
think that the person that should be
held accountable is surely Stanley
Johnson right when he gives interviews
again now he should be vigorously
pressed on this by journalists about
exactly what the truth is and he should
be made to say his version of events on
the record and be rightly challenged I
mean that to me seems to be who should
be targeted in this way not Fiona Bruce
I absolutely agree with UPS because what
has happened now we've taken the focus
off the perpetrator you know whether it
was a one-off or not
um as Fiona said and she would have
known she knows about domestic abuse and
perpetrators
um and it's not just a one-off so what's
happened now in the media we've taken
the focus off the perpetrator as per
usual and focusing on something else
which is Fiona and like I said I support
Fiona and I know she would not have said
that um through her own uh opinion that
is just something she had to say and
also can I just say as well you know you
said about the government
shame on like Fiona no shame on the
government when they don't sort their
magistrates and judges Aid in court when
I had to go to a victim last week
because she'd been strangled by her
perpetrator so ferociously her neck was
black but yet he walked from court
because the magistrate knew nothing
really about domestic abuse and violence
and give him a 12-month custodial
sentence suspended for two years so
shame on the government there well I'm
I'm equally as angry as you about that
as I was about the poor boy that we
interviewed yesterday who was wrongly
tarnished as being a rapist by a total
fantasist and she ends up getting an
eight-year sentence for ruining so many
lives he would have got 22 years his
lawyers had told him had he been found
guilty of all the charges against him
Larissa this wider issue of canceled
culture there is a feeling that the woke
left and I I think you identify as one
um but you can correct me if you like um
that the woke left take a sort of weird
Glee
in canceling people whose views you
don't share do you think that's right
and do you think it's healthy for a
democracy
no I don't understand where this idea
that pencil culture is somehow aligned
with the left exists when so many
leftists are supportive of
transformative Justice which is all
about taking time for education for
relearning for unlearning things
um and then coming back into things and
that's why when we're saying that Fiona
Bruce has taken a step back maybe she
took a minute to think why have I
received so much backlash who may I have
harmed or perhaps not no and haven't got
told by Refuge she she couldn't be an
ambassador anymore that's what happened
what grounds are you saying that appears
I know that for a fact
you know sorry can you bring a sauce or
something I'm just telling you it's true
it isn't all about you so what's the
point telling you my Souls no I'm not
telling you myself
that's what that is what happened
okay so perp is that's what happened but
per the public reports in the news about
what happened uh Fiona Bruce has uh has
decided to take a step back yeah let me
tell you Larissa I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna teach you how to suck journalistic
eggs this formative stage of your
burgeoning career however every time a
public figure involved in the Scandal
says they've suddenly decided to take a
step back it's very rarely their idea
it's usually somebody else's name and if
you'd like to be less patronizing that
would be far provided violence
um in this in this segment so I
apologize for being Patrick
I think this is an opportunity for
learning growth yeah so I think it could
be a positive thing it's not about
taking it with Glee It's a it's about
seeing the bright side of this I would
love to see the bright side uh good to
talk to you Larissa thank you very much
indeed Rachel thank you very much Esther
you're staying with us you're gonna
bring it back a little later I think
okay is this a budget from a government
that's finally competent well the
conservatives cocked it up too many
times for us to forgive them we'll
debate that next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
thank you
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember a if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
well the UK economy looks like it's
finally seeing the tiniest fragment of
Life the chancellor Jeremy Hunter to
Liberty's annual budget trying to undo
the Colossal collateral damage caused by
lettuce Liz and her disastrous
Chancellor quarteng's mini budget from
Hell well the good news is the UK May
avoid recession this year we've got told
today but we're still lagging way behind
our International peers and we're the
only major economy predicted to shrink
in 2023 should labor worry though that
we're finally seeing a vaguely competent
conservative government and prime
minister Chancellor or it's too much
damage being done for the tourist
recover in time for an election which is
still nearly two years away well Jordan
I've talked to these business
correspondent was Anna Lockwood the
daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and Esther crack you has
remained with me
uh okay well welcome Rosanna this is
your debut
um you're apparently the business brains
of this operation so off you go that's a
terrifying thought isn't it I I saw Kate
Clark earlier um on a rival Network that
should not be mentioned um but he was
quite interestingly kind of summary of
this he thought he was actually
comforting to finally see a slightly
boring quite safe but well-received
budget which didn't scare the children
and settled things down and nothing's
collapsed as a result and he said the
bar's low but it was nice to see that
from his party that's exactly what I
would have pointed out we're coming off
an extremely low base here when you
consider that the doldrums the UK
economy's been in now I don't want to be
any kind of British declinist but we're
in a sort of state of managed Decline
and we have been for some time you know
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt standing there in
the Commons today patting themselves on
the back saying look we're not even
gonna enter into a recession this year
but we're actually looking just at
stagnation and set and as you said the
worst performer out of the G7 countries
it growth also is something that you
need to address in a very desperate way
what are the top lines from this budget
which you think are really going to have
any kind of substantive difference
you know what I'd prefer to think of it
in the politics point of view because
the next election is going to be fought
on families and child care so this
headline grabbing 30 hours free a week
for child care the devil is in the
detail on that one but it sounds good it
sounds good it's labor territory sounds
great is labor territory but it's
staggered it's coming in over the course
of a few years and it only benefits
certain amount of people right now you
know Devil's always in the detail with
these things but it's given labor
something to think about they've come
out uh conservatives today and some say
it lurching everywhere ever more towards
this kind of welfare state that you
wouldn't expect to see other than that
it was very straight down the middle
conservative budget well here's the
question for you is it actually a
conservative budget I've seen some
conservative pundits immediately
reacting saying look this is a Gordon
Brown budget it's not conservatism we're
seeing here but can they be
old-fashioned conservatives given the
financial state of the country in our
economy which is in great part due to
the conservative government that has
been in power for the last decade or so
so yes they have painted themselves into
a corner and they are having to make
decisions that you might see more
towards the center even to the left in
some places and that is going to be a
struggle with their back benches with
their Tory back benches as well to sell
them okay Esther do you think it's a
conservative absolutely not you know
I've made the point that the
conservatives since Cameron have been
varying shades of social Democrats
there's no such thing as anything could
they be anything else given a pandemic
and a war region yes they could because
I was making the point like the child
care sort of allowances that they've
increased I was like why would you go
why are you going to pay someone a
stranger to take care of a child when
you could actually just pay the mother
to stay at home with her child that's a
very fundamentally at least on a sort of
theoretical level just not conservative
at all and so many people are making the
point that how is this a conservative
budget where they're sticking to raising
corporation tax yeah but we've tried the
Liz truss quasi-guating route of yes
slashing taxes Christmas has come early
here you go everyone boom everything
collapsed we had she had no way of
trying so my point being Kevin you can't
actually Implement what you would say
are old-fashioned cut the taxes you know
all this kind of thing which an
old-fashioned conservative would
probably want to see happen because we
tried this dramatically and it was a
spectacular disaster yeah but they
haven't done it for a long time remember
David Cameron put vat up to a record 20
12 billion quid straight off look are
they socialists in disguised no no I
just think they're incompetent now they
haven't they haven't they haven't got a
plan hang on I think I think it's
makeshift makeshift
mediocre growth I'm not saying it's a
great budget but what I was saying is it
had it had a whiff of Competency I think
you're overstating I think I think
Jeremy Hunt and Richard love them more
it doesn't matter what party you're on I
like the fact they just seem vaguely
competent yeah after what happened with
Boris Johnson and then Liz truss and
quieting and all that nonsense I feel
slightly reassured that there may be
some grown-ups in the room that they're
not really as bad as the last yes
we'll see you over the next few days you
will see that income tax is going to go
up 29 billion over the period because
rates are going to be frozen you will
see spending on health and education
both big areas problems are going to go
down you will see child care which I
think was and I thought was the most
promising development isn't properly
funded and won't come in until 2029 at
the earliest fully so some kids who are
now nine months supposed to be going to
get child care they'll be the back end
of um primary if you like anything in
the budget yeah uh let me think about it
though
11p well there you go 11p off a pain oh
there you go there we are wow about that
I will welcome that how are you are you
happy I will wholeheartedly toast that
breaking Kevin McGuire happy hour budget
because he gets to get a cheaper pint
yeah so Rosanna let me ask you this
question though will any of this matter
if the jungle drums are about Banks
going under starts to really get a grip
and we head back to 2008 now is that
possible it look anything is possible
appears but be wary of conflating what's
happening in international financial
markets with the domestic UK politics
currently the banking situation I know
our viewers might have even heard about
Credit Suisse today that is a major
concern but we're not yet in 2000 but if
they go on Credit Suisse could could
that have a domino effect
has the effect
psychology in the market so if people
start pulling their Investments out of
banks in Europe and Bank UK than it
could but there have been systems put in
place since the 2008 financial crash
that means banks are what we call well
capitalized you've got better systems
and Pace better regulation as far as we
know at the bank of England last we
heard from them on Monday with the
English banks are in a good so if we
play this clip back in two months time I
will be easy it won't be under it won't
be under the blooper of the Year section
I hope not I called Russia wrong so I
hope I'm not calling
reverse Nostradamus right yeah Kevin are
you worried about it you worried about
this fragility in the banking system
again you've got to be good yeah
economies and are connected yeah
internationally and we know one of the
reasons Britain Got High inflation had a
lot of problems Putin's invasion of
Ukraine after covert I can see that for
instance one of the reasons Britain is
now about to avoid recession which is
good news in the budget two-thirds of
the reason you've actually really rather
enjoyed this budget no I haven't been
two-thirds of stuff two-thirds of the
reasons are international including
Energy prices dropping pretty pretty
rapidly right but that politically yes
so this could actually play into Rishi
sunak's hands he's still got nearly two
years if he needs it right to call him
election that's a long time in policies
this trust lasted 44 days right yes and
if they were able to see it say the war
gets resolved in some way I think it's a
big if but if it if it did Energy prices
come right back down inflation really
eases right and you start to see real
green shoots where she's sitting at
Jeremy Hunt if they ride that wave of
optimism coming out of all this and say
we've helped steer us off the Rocks into
Karma Waters it's not a bad electoral
proposition if I was if I was curious
darling I was thinking this today
he hasn't really sold his vision of what
he thinks Britain should he doesn't have
one I mean I think even labor fans would
would say he hasn't he's got he's got a
paint in very Vivid primary colors right
what he will do and his nightmare
actually is competency from the new
Administration and trust and that's
that's the biggest issue if Richie sunac
because he's the most trusted in the
market he's giving us these five-point
pledge yeah which he made to me in
person and down the street so come back
the end of the year he could actually he
could make a lot exactly and you know it
doesn't help kiss armor that his
personalities like plywood
we're going to hold into this
by the end of the year when hopefully we
can come back and do this again and you
can give me my report card on those five
things uh I I am confident that we will
have delivered on them in the country at
that point will be able to say hang on
this guy
said he was going to do these things and
he's done them and that's what I want to
be judged by because I think politicians
say lots of things and the country's
probably quite frankly tired of it right
what they want is someone to just do the
things that they say and that's what I'm
going to do Yes actually that that old
trick of having a leader who actually
says what he means and does what he says
he's going to do that would be truly
amazing hang on he set his own homework
and he's marking his own homework that
is true inflation was going to more than
half are you saying I've been played
well you know Rosanna final word giving
your a debutante Pier Starman has
promised to make the UK the strongest
before me economy in the G7 if labor
come into power so try holding into that
that is a very bold boat uh well thank
you uh very much indeed I think you're
leaving us because your brain's business
and that's the end of the business
um next time we'll promote you to other
matters you two are coming back I think
um
well next to that the special prosecutor
who bound to take down Alec Baldwin has
stepped aside in a rare boost for the
disgraced star because he's still facing
jail as he's been convicted in the court
of public opinion we'll debate that
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
everybody is aging but let's be honest
nobody wants to so what if we could just
make it stop well Brian Johnson says
he's the real life Benjamin Buck he's a
team of 30 doctors thousands of pills
millions of dollars and he made his body
five years younger now he'll tell me how
and why appears Morgan uncensored
special can we has he and should we turn
back time
please
[Music]
gonna be must see television then it's
an extraordinary story can you turn back
time can you arrest the aging process
should we I'll be mucking around with
science and biology I don't know it's
going to be fascinating well ever since
Helena Hutchins was shot and killed
almost at a rust the movie in October
2021 the producer and star of the film
Alec Baldwin has maintained an arrogant
refusal to accept any responsibility for
what happened she left behind a husband
and a young child Baldwin still seemed
to see himself as the real victim of
this tragedy here he is doing a cynical
PR round a couple of months ago after
the shooting
do you feel guilt no no
I feel that there is I I feel that that
that
someone is responsible for what happened
and I can't say who that is but I know
it's not me
it's pleaded not guilty to involuntary
manslaughters in our school to win in
the case after the special prosecutor
has just resigned following a challenge
from Baldwin's law is interesting and
discuss all this is Fox News host and
lawyer eraldo Rivera Heraldo great to
see you
um you know every time I see yeah
just repeat repeatedly stare down a
camera or look at an interview and say I
feel no guilt for what happened I'm like
really you literally pointed a gun at a
woman's I mean accidentally yes you
pointed a gun at a woman's head and you
pulled the trigger and you killed her
how can you not at the very least feel
guilt for that
well I agree with you certainly
arrogance is at play but also
desperation peers here's a man on top of
the world uh admittedly he wasn't
starring in the biggest roles but he was
a busy actor he was well known he was on
everyone's A-list and then suddenly now
he's uh he's a killer so he's doing
everything he possibly can he's mounted
a very vigorous defense and now as you
alluded to it the special prosecutor has
been removed from the case it has little
to do with Alec Baldwin's case per se
but it has everything to do with the
state constitution in New Mexico where
you're not permitted to be a prosecutor
in the Judiciary at the same time you
were a member of the state legislature
as Andrea Reeb is so it was that
technicality that his ferocious defense
team which is easy on anything and
everything in their uh in their quest to
keep him out of jail seized on what's
interesting is in her statement she
still reiterated that in her eyes she
wants the prosecution to focus on the
evidence and the facts which clearly
show a complete disregard for basic
safety protocols that led to the death
of Helena Hutchins so she's making her
feelings again as she has done
repeatedly pretty clear where she thinks
responsibility lies and that include
Sally Baldwin
they tried the prosecutors to present an
image that has both fairness and
strength the old adage no one is above
the law they're going to prosecute uh
the the the king and the Pauper uh with
equal equal Vigor if they if they
violated the law the problem is often in
Celebrity cases in the United States
they go a special energy to get the bad
guy to get the famous guy knowing that
it's going to be not only on the legal
page of the newspaper but also the
entertainment section so in this case
for instance going after enhanced
circumstances in the involuntary
manslaughter which would have guaranteed
required really by law jail time yeah 18
months of jail time they got the
enhanced circumstance thrown out because
it was uh it was uh you know to uh too
arduous a charge in this particular
instance but Alec Baldwin still if
convicted faces up to that year and a
half uh Behind Bars and I think the
state's case is very strong loaded guns
don't fire themselves uh accident of
course it was an accident but still uh
when you point to a loaded gun at
someone and you pulled the trigger there
is Criminal culpability even if you are
Alec Baldwin well you know we had a case
in Britain uh only last week where a
woman was walking along a sidewalker
pavement and another woman came along
and rushed past her and she pushed her
away she was on a bicycle this other
lady pushed her away and she fell in
front of a vehicle and died and the
woman that did the pushing of somebody
who was on the sidewalk on a bike and
going a bit fast the woman who did that
got three years in prison and I did
think at the moment I read that well
what about Alec Baldwin
you know it's not entirely dissimilar
and yet one person yeah three years
well he is a Hollywood star just get
away with terrible
I I think that I mean in my personal
opinion I don't know all the facts in
the bicycle pushing the case but that
does seem very severe uh punishment
maybe above and beyond the pale and I'm
not sure what role publicity played uh
in the imposition of such a severe
sentence for what was clearly clearly an
accident unless there was some evidence
that the woman was ticked off as soon as
she was doing the shoving you know what
she didn't have geralda in the case of
Alec Baldwin you know what she she
didn't she didn't have Alec Baldwin's
massive highly expensive legal team it's
probably what it came down to
I thought you were going to say she
didn't have me defending her well all
that in the case
in the case of Alec Baldwin he claims he
did not pull the trigger of this of this
uh antique weapon it was it was farcical
the FBI the uh Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms people the federal experts all
tested this gun six ways to Sunday and
all came to the same conclusion it would
not could not have been fired but for
the fact that it was cocked and someone
pulled the trigger so he claims he
didn't pull the trigger who did uh you
know the Western uh Gods of the New
Mexico planes uh you know I I think that
Alec Baldwin is still in very serious
legal Jeopardy however he's fighting
tooth and nail and I I I think that I
personally believe he will be convicted
and he will at least get jail time
suspended at the very least uh but I I
think that uh his desperation has more
to do I think with his career with the
Civil liability that he faces uh you
know he's uh he he's not out of the
woods even if he is acquitted no I agree
well talking of desperation
um there's the ongoing saga of our old
friends Harry and Megan and you and I
have argued about these two quite a lot
um who are apparently are making their
minds up whether to attend the
coronation we have a little VT to play
first
they're so racist they wanted to know
how Brown the baby's gonna be I'm like
that's not racist
because even black people want to know
it has been several months now since our
beloved Queen has died all Canadians are
finding it hard to go on all Canadians
that is except for our first Guest The
Prince and his wife
[Applause]
it was reported that the organizers of
King Charles's coronation have
officially invited Meghan Markle and
this is nice at a starting salary of 19
an hour
just complaining I was like did she hit
the light-skinned Lottery
now araldo you and I know when when
America turns that way and turns you
into a laughing stock the game's up
isn't it
well I I really do believe I mean I may
be uh you know a minority of one here
but I do believe that Harry still has
considerable Goodwill certainly uh in my
mind for the fact that he's a war hero
uh and he was a long time spare I I even
felt sympathy I must add uh uh you know
to minimize my own statement for prince
Andrew uh who was a hero in the
Falklands War so Harry and Andrew both
uh you know certifiable Heroes uh you
know great Patriots who were extremely
flawed and did things that are uh are
terrible I mean Andrew's case I don't
have to relitigate Jeffrey Epstein but
in Harry's case the whole Nazi uniform
and some of the other whining that as uh
has happened I still believe though he's
Charming he's handsome he's young he has
a lovely wife as soon as the the uh the
prince and princess begin their uh uh
you know their uh the the children begin
their own public City Tour I think
Hearts will melt you know
I'll let you get away with about 20
seconds of this Guff but I've got to
tell you eventually the scales are going
to fall from your eyes eventually it's
going to take you about another five
appearances but eventually I will get
you to confess on Piers Morgan
uncensored that you finally turned and
actually appears you were right they're
a pair of little waste rules who want
their Royal cake and eat it you will
I'll crack you
we'll see we'll see I I still want to
give them the benefit of the doubt there
is no doubt rather like with Alec
Baldwin and the trigger there is no
doubt Geraldo but great to have you on
the show thank you very much
you two of yours I might follow it my
pleasure great man around the Rivera uh
well next tonight Donald Trump's
publishing 150 letters he's received
over the years from the great and good
he reckons that they'll show that Queen
Elizabeth II and Princess Dino were
among the others Who quotes kissed his
ass really we'll discuss that next
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no out with the people's
Channel no what are you every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
and coming off on the talk we'll be
picking apart the chances back to work
budget and a new scheme could see
hundreds of prisoners released early in
order to free up spaces in jails and
Playboy is coming back not to the top
shelf of the news agent but it's
rebranding for the digital age we'll
talk about all of that and more shut at
the back piers at nine o'clock see you
then foreign
[Music]
about that
um I'm joined by talk TV contributor
Esther kraku and daughter still here
come on joined by them uh Kevin and
that's just stay with me all right let's
talk about some stuff Donald Trump has
apparently kept all the letters
sycophantic letters from people many of
whom turned on him once he ran for
president so he's doing it to make a
point really about look at you like
doing Oprah Winfrey paying homage to him
or something but he includes apparently
the letters from the queen and from
Princess Diana and he says that all of
them kiss my ass is apparently quote
Esther is I can't imagine that includes
her majesty the queen most certainly not
um he is the pettiest man alive it's
quite funny though I mean if it is
people like Oprah and others who've
really turned on him it's quite funny
that he's not just going to publish here
are the sycophantic letters I mean I'm
just hoping some of mine are in there
I'm trying to get the interviews but but
it is it is quite funny oh absolutely I
mean chop was an urban figure of
admiration he's a Jay-Z song for
goodness sake all these people that
complain about him being a horrible
racist they used to rap about him yeah
however I think there should be limits
to the shamelessness because to say that
the Queen and Princess Diana wiped his
there are there are no limits to Trump's
famous which is why Kevin I just you
can't rule him out of winning again you
can't no you can't no I don't want to
call him again but you can't you can't
say he won't interesting poll tonight
actually of Independence in America who
apparently in a matchup of trump V Biden
they Biden would win with Independence
been in a matchup of Ron DeSantis the
governor of Florida this Rising
Republican star he would beat Biden and
that's a really interesting yeah writers
are going to be easy to beat because
he's the incumbent
yes and I could see that but I think
DeSantis is a much more difficult
one thing the Santos is alive yeah right
you don't have to open the fridge and
woo them out
can get slightly exaggerated I mean I'm
sorry we'll see
um Oscar's glamor Esther a very
glamorous young lady uh always on this
show but I've noticed you know you have
you have standards that you keep up to
right these standards seem to drop as
fast as the clothing at the Oscars with
a series of female celebrities rocking
up at the Vanity Fair party basically
wearing underwear with a kind of skimpy
see-through top I know who you referring
we've got them all here right yeah
um I mean it was just more and more of
them rocked up basically naked with a
couple of bars of clothing over them
this is not what the Oscars are supposed
to be about well where's the glamor in
this well this is like a bunch of
strippers we're living in an attention
by the way no problem with strippers but
not at the oysters yeah but this is the
point because everyone's trying to shock
attention is the name of the game
everyone wants that hot take on social
media so everyone tries to do the most
shocking thing but the least shocking
thing is being naked because that's what
they all do well look at Kevin look at
the Oscars back in the the this is 50s
this is right yeah I mean look it's a
completely elegant Vibe yeah I'm trying
to think which I prefer actually
heavy but of course but the truth is
they just want to get noticed but the
great thing about the old stars is they
didn't feel that desperate thirst to be
noticed right they didn't need it now
it's all like look at my naked flesh
because they had something else look at
my talent and my glamor and my beauty
they had something else to offer they
were talented actresses with a certain
standard now these actresses singers
whatever they're all strippers first
they all have to show how good their
bodies are before they do anything so
what is Emily radachowski doing there
anyway yeah how does she qualified to be
anywhere near an Oscar's party all the
Oscars you've got to fill the Sinners
yeah it ends up with more clothes than
she normally wears I.E not very many but
what's she doing this I mean Kim
Kardashian or something ridiculous um
one thing I did feel exercised about uh
A Man Called Paul Sorvino who you'll all
know he was poorly in Goodfellas right
take a clip to remind us
but I got nowhere else to go Paulie
You're All I've got and I really really
need your help I really do
expect this
now I gotta tie my back
one of the great roles in one of the
all-time great movies he had so many
other roles in great movies completely
ignored in the immemorium section and
his daughter who's an oscar-winning
actress Mira Savino tweeted his baffling
beyond belief my beloved father was just
left after the Oscars forgot about Paul
Sorvino the rest of us never will and I
won't because I got to know him quite
well and he's a delightful man and
actually when we launched this show
nearly a year ago we asked him to supply
a video we haven't played this before
and he sent this
Pierce I heard you got a new show I'm
happy for you get a chance you see that
big brain again and listen I guess
somebody may not watch it you tell me
who it is I'll get him worked
fantastic great
character a great character great actor
and I actually believed him I think he
would have died yeah
um but just uh Mira and all the family
and Dee and his partner just we didn't
forget him he was one of the greats and
he should have been mentioned that in
memoriam and I feel very uh Angry on
your behalf that he got overlooked in
that way it's wrong isn't it but some of
that stature dies it's a really bad era
particularly when the Oscars themselves
are under so much scrutiny and people
what's the point and when they go on for
three and a half hours you couldn't find
10 seconds to show a picture of Paul
Sorvino this is one of the stars of
Goodfellas really they're too busy
virtue signaling yes yeah that's they
are yeah they literally are aren't they
and the two busy looking people like
Hugh Grant in the building when he
didn't realize you could allow Hugh
Grant in and have a proper tribute yeah
exactly it's not a choice honestly Hugh
Grant like I said he should be banned
from every award ceremony ever again if
you turn up into that graceless on a red
carpet that's it done done he's a good
actor though isn't it is he he always
plays Hugh Grant yeah he's the same role
he always plays smug false English fraud
right which is what he is look at it
look at it there's a lot of them about
Sir
you're not exactly present company no no
certainly not because I'd like to remind
you I'm Irish yeah
so tomorrow I'm interviewing Brian
Johnson who's this guy who wants to
reverse the aging process what do you
think of that um I don't want I don't
know why we're so scared of Aging
I I think aging is a beautiful was it
right for you because your young spring
chicken no it's at our age the problem
everything starts to fall apart you're
nearer the birth and the coffin
serious I don't understand would you
like to reverse it Kevin or even stop
the aging process I'm still 36 actually
in my head are you sure yeah but so my
theory is everybody looks in a mirror
and sees somebody about 30 to 35. you
never see someone aging past that to
yourself it's weird we don't find it if
you ever get it
thank you Pat good to see you keep it
uncensored tomorrow night Brian Dawson
don't want to miss that good night
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
about one two
thank you
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if your thing